gene regulation can occur at many
different levels so it can go right at
the beginning in the activation of the
gene in the DNA in the genome through
the synthesis of the RNA through its
splicing through export from the nucleus
through translation in the cytoplasm
through degradation of the RNA all of
these steps can be regulated and in fact
most of them are under different
circumstances gene regulation is the way
that different genes are turned on and
off in different cells to give us
different cells different organs and
ultimately different organisms so the
way we used to think about RNA was as
the middleman between DNA and protein
you've got DNA which encodes the genes
carries all the information that gets
passed down from generation to
generation and proteins of course are
what makes up most of our cells and body
the hair cell the hair the skin cells
bone etcetera etcetera is made up of
proteins and so RNA had this reputation
as being the the in-between of those two
things and in fact what we know now is
that RNA was probably the original
molecule of life this idea that the
original replicating chemical entity
might have actually been made of RNA RNA
can do base pairing the same way DNA can
and so you can get replication but RNA
also can fold up and into interesting
three-dimensional molecules the same way
that proteins can and so it can act as
an enzyme to catalyze chemical reactions
that are necessary for a life question
then is why do we have DNA in the
nucleus and the answer under that
scenario would be that that DNA is a
good storage molecule is much more
stable in RNA and then in fact it you
served RNA at some point in evolution as
the information molecule and then left
RNA in at least until until a few years
ago in this poultry informational role
but now we're beginning to appreciate
and in fact RNA might be much more
central to the metabolism of the cell
and regulation of the cell than we
previously thought our view of the
genome is is changing and changing very
quickly it for a long time it was seen
as a kind of desert of evolutionary junk
with the occasional island of protein
coding sequences but now our view is
changing and not everybody agrees with
this and not everybody is even aware of
this change but it is changing quickly
to a view of that the genome is really
an extremely sophisticated information
suite and that most of the information
being transacted by the genome is being
transacted through RNA regulatory
networks which set the settings for the
control of growth and development in
multicellular organisms the story is how
you integrate all of this new
information how proteins work and rnase
work in the context of each other
clearly transcriptional regulatory
systems must be integrated and so I
think the critical question is how if
you think about a human we have roughly
a hundred trillion cells in a very very
precise arrangement you know all of the
dozens of muscles in your face to create
the range of human expressions the bones
and the finger and the brain and the
information for programming the ontogeny
and functioning of this has to lie
somewhere we have the same number of
protein coding genes many of which are
equivalent between us and as a simple
nematode worm that only has 1,000 cells
so go figure
you had information in DNA that
information got transferred to an RNA
intermediate and that RNA information
got translated into protein and of
course that's still true but now we know
that the information is flowing in much
more interesting ways and that there's
information flowing in both directions
the information can flow also from the
RNA back to the to the DNA and so I
think we have to think of the the genome
as not just a central information
repository but something that's
interacting constantly with its
environment and many of those
interactions are going to be carried out
by RNA and it looks very much like
evolution discovered through the use of
RNA the power of digital communication
and control systems are billion years
we did now micro RNA is small RNA
molecules are roughly 22 nucleotides in
length they have no catalytic activity
whatsoever as far as we know what they
do is recognize a target sequence
another RNA usually a messenger RNA and
a target that messenger RNA thereby for
to inhibit this translation and perhaps
to its destruction and that is mediated
by a generic protein complex called a
RISC complex so you can dial up
regulatory circuits but simply by
producing a different micro RNA you
don't have to reproduce an entire
infrastructure the infrastructure is
generic so this is what I mean by a
digital control system I don't mean in
this context on off but rather a very
compact sequence specific string that
conveys information to a target which
then recruits the appropriate
infrastructure to convert that message
back into an analogue action now if you
think about it exactly the same thing
happens when you order a DVD online you
send digital signal so the product code
in your credit card number which whizzed
over the wires or optical fibers and
then at the end of the line somebody
interprets that message and puts a DVD
in a bag and post it to so the
information transfer is far more
efficient far more flexible and and far
more malleable in an evolutionary
context I think we'll see in the future
an increasing role for RNA in gene
regulation I think we'll see expansion
of the systems we know about more
excitingly we're going to discover new
systems that I'm sure of that are RNA
based we're just realizing that we've
only got to first base and we have a
long way to go and most of the journey
forward is going to be dissecting
analyzing and and rebuilding an
understanding of these massively
parallel and extremely sophisticated RNA
regulatory circuits which really do
underpin our complexity and the irony I
think is that what was dismissed as junk
because it wasn't understood will turn
out to hold the secret of human
complexity including our cognitive
complex
and that's where we're going over the
next 10 to 50 years
you
science is published by triple-a s the
science Society